we're up I grew up in the thickest part
which is the projects and there's body
hunters I was a runaway
I left my family because I was
hot-headed no religion
that's what well yeah and I started out
drinking and partying mixing start doing
things that wasn't daddy growth
can be better than doing
but eventually the fight started coming
because I was young and girls was
jealous because I was younger than them
and I was prettier than you are
because I can't more attention but then
I think I'd like it that I had to start
fighting because it made me who I am
today is my struggle made me strong so
these are prison huh
I've been prison I went to prison at the
age of 18 I escaped from civil brand in
1995 October 1st 99 five hours the first
me and Rebecca daughter was the first
two individuals to every state civil
brand
I was scared me I don't know then about
prison I thought he want to go to kiss
me somebody busy so I escaped from some
brand we were to zoom it's the county
jail for me it was on the news that
ruling overseers right skate from there
I was on in there on America's Most
Wanted other features have you seen this
they caught me 32 days later they called
her the next day I did my first person
turn at 18 I'm 42 years old I've got I
have 10 I have 13 prison terms one
strike I've been down here since I was
13 I work the streets
I've done a little bit everything over
here parents growing up my parents my
mother was an addict and my dad I stayed
with my dad but I always wanted my mom
but my mom was on her drugs and stuff
and last time remember I had with my mom
when she was on a patio naked she was on
her PCP and she had a trip down her
throat she couldn't talk and my dad took
me from her and my dad he was a he was a
addict itself but he was more of
functional heading but then he things
got out of hand and him and his current
wife got into it so he left me with my
grandmother my grandmother was a
churchgoer
so she said keep up with me that much
she just I just did what I wanted to do
you know disregard her
[ __ ] I found myself on the streets
after the gangbang after I left Nixon
garden because it got too much I headed
to Bill Martin I start working on
streets in Bell Gardens at the age of 14
and I rate and we're getting ready
that's good
that's lovely down a little bit I've
been cheated God was somebody older he
was things Norman who said he was 40 I
was 15 and we came down here and that's
when I started Kent got here and I
started selling drugs gangbanging Warren
and then we went back to Compton that's
when I became I'm from Southside I'm
actually a [ __ ] i grilled with the
Bloods but I um so then I started
selling drugs down here and I start
selling drag down here I was making a
lots of money I was making so much money
but my mother and the dying mother died
and I end up started using okay so
you're selling they're not using
and I was young I was smoking weed PCP
but never crank I start excusing us to
became my best customer
I became my best customer
I had to lose a lot of people I thought
next opportunity but I didn't care my
mother was wrong I wanted to be known
started suck what history's again am I
and I started I started changing because
downtown changed people bring things out
of you that you don't want to that you
know that was there
just got me thinking
downtown is uh it's actually I've been
dying out what's happened out here
almost 30 years 30 years was the
craziest thing you see her the craziest
thing I've seen when I seen a woman
getting pushed out the frontier window I
think a woman two people actually in the
frontier
I was outside outside hustling her for I
don't know what floor she came from but
she came because I was outside and I was
BAM now I've never seen nothing like
that I was in the Cecil and a girl she
jumped she jumped they said she jumped
but I'll do the job room 742 she failed
but she lived yeah so she lived for two
days and she when she turned herself she
could fail we she fell she turned
herself on when she is in anything she
was saying please door please don't let
me die please let me be along to tell
you know she I think she may have told
her but she endured i but she lived two
days after the census be so honored or
staying no maintenance
that's a bet step four hi yes that was
one of the crazy things I've seen sorry
no not actually the man I got caught on
fire that's it on fire not too long ago
that was the craziest thing I've seen
yeah obviously I've seen enough visit
Iran I have seconds I have I become a
mother to have my laughing
I've had drug-related babies my daughter
she won a scholarship for beating her
eyes she's um she's she's a nurse now
she graduated st. Mary's she's the best
part of me she overcame all this hermana
leaving I left in a hospital when she
was a preemie
to go get hot I had the staples in my
stomach and I left the hospital with the
staples on my stomach to come down here
died and my baby was in the thing about
but I have seven kids
and another one asking price for your is
the last why I'm raising but right now
he says my cousin because I had went to
prison I had my son with me that's the
only one I raised but I went to prison
for sales and my coz I get my cousin
temporary guardianship and I don't want
him back down here so I'm trying to get
me together so I get my baby back
I've been cleaning for five months three
days
I got clean from Craig by smoking
crystal I wake myself are and remember I
did that and then down I don't swell I
don't have the taste with crystal heart
because I look at everybody and they
start picking a face I see certain
people and there there is to it you know
and I don't want to be that I've been
I've done a lot out here and I want out
they got that my brain is still somewhat
so I just take one day at a time I say
today just for today I won't get so
tomorrow and I wake up I say just with
that yeah I've gone to a time in my life
where daddy I lost my baby day people
think that I had told him somebody down
here so it's like but where I come from
you're not supposed to supposed to have
proof or something like that instead of
just putting that on down so I have to
go prove myself to a lot of people that
I didn't do what they thought I did and
it made me realize that they was never
my friend at all in the first place so
I'm separating myself
oh yeah six Big Daddy 17 centimeters I
have
and actually at an autopsy my son my
last baby his dad is in prison and my
husband I had math we got married three
years ago he's in prison
he helped me raise my son he'd adopted
my son they tried to take my baby and
everything when I was in prison but uh
he's gonna stop to that his name is like
my baby probably have more kids I had
two abortions were you his name's
Christopher
is 26 Ronny is 24 should be 25 reality
is 19 forever is 17 Asian Isaiah is 15
Amir is 12 and no arrears 13 and life is
six
what would you say the whole group I
could tell them right now I would tell
them I apologize for
not being there for you for missing out
on all the time that you needed me to be
there if it's not too late I hope we can
be friends get to know each other
it's not a day that goes by and I don't
think you and I wonder how you look when
if you take it on me like I'm thinking
about you
but I never get y'all smile I never get
your spin I always I love to sell my
babies winning
but I love you guys
you can clean as the first yeah it's
great these
basement apartment thank you